gang real quick before we get the
episode started we got a hot new merch
alert
want everybody to know that if you want
to get down on the cards if you missed
them we got them back in stock baby pick
up a pack and kippy what else we got oh
baby
beer koozies drink with a little bit of
class with your like a gentleman beer
koozie packs of three available only
guys go to uh ru
garbage.bigcartel.com the link will be
in the description of the youtube and
the audio click it limited run while
supplies last yeah get it play the game
with your family get a hammer it's a bit
of a koozie summer ain't over yet baby
do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage yep it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they go to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day down here in aunt
toddy's basement she wants me to make an
announcement to the folks out there okay
she wants you to come check her out
tonight at the open mic at the comedy
cabaret in north east
philadelphia great place she's getting
into the family business okay she's
working out five minutes she's got a bit
about you to kill i don't know what to
tell you so please go and check her out
my co-host is coming at you unemused
from right next to me
ceo of are you garbage he's really an
international businessman to be honest
with you he's kind of the head bozo
around here so show him a little respect
give it up for kevin james wright hey
gang happy to be here a little bit of
business as always please make sure you
rate view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true the roof cooking
patreon.com i mean what are we doing
that thing's [ __ ] that thing's really
cooking over there's that money and then
we just drop merch go get the merch the
link will be in the description we got
beer koozies and the game the card games
cards are back baby get them cards while
they're hot how about a quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up dudes
welcome back buddy good to see you buddy
we love you and gang
we could not be more excited and i mean
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time everybody's
been asking for hanging out in all of
her comments you gotta get her on gotta
get her on she's over here from the left
coast we had a grabber while she was in
town she is a very funny very successful
stand-up comedian actor podcaster and
writer she has appeared in grand theft
auto 5 the long dumb road those who
can't this is not happening your mom's
house gotham comedy live money from
strangers adam devine's house party 15
episodes of chelsea lately
last call with carson daly rose battle
at midnight wtf with mark maron lights
out with david spade she's in the comedy
store documentary you've seen her on
good for you with whitney cummings of
course the joe rogan experience and
she's one of the extremely funny
co-hosts of the amazing podcast trash
tuesday but the big question about his
mind today yeah here today
how many times have i raped
who molested you to get you here she's
from a small town called philadelphia
pennsylvania and the devil knows their
own ladies and gentlemen give it up for
the one the only andy letterman
hi guys thank you for having me thanks
for coming good to see you buddy i'm
sorry i was three and a half hours sure
yeah i
thought at one point i'm like did we
mean next tuesday
big time in this i like it no no no i
was like i wonder if i think i'm big
time but
i mean a little i guess
i just well i don't know how to get
around new york anymore i'm like it's so
embarrassing i really like i don't know
how to do it yeah well also i want to
share i want to share the text that i
got hey i'm right hey i'm running late i
have to run in my hotel to wash off my
swamp ass then i'm heading up
i know i i honestly didn't know you
would gain so much weight i wouldn't
have washed it off to make you feel a
little solidarity
but i um yeah
she said when she walked in yeah i i was
hard it's hard to miss
i thought the black would slim me out a
little bit
no i um yeah no i don't know how to get
around this town
it's tough well that's changed too since
you've been yeah i mean this
everything's all the subway is [ __ ] up
the the taxis are from and i'm going
like what's what's which direction i was
like which direction's nine i was here
for how many years i was here four years
the first time in one year the next time
so that's actually not that much so
you're saying you got geogra like
geographically confused i don't know
where the hell i am i don't know what
i'm doing i don't know which part of
town i'm staying in lay off the
goofballs
spring streets near it is
where are you staying while you're in
town what area
um i think so we just said that oh you
did is that what you're talking about i
apologize i was like do you want the
room number yeah
yeah you know what i realized i don't
want airbnb i don't want to do it i
don't want to be in your [ __ ] i don't
know you have to meet up with the person
you got to make sure everything it's
yeah it can be a little wacky i used to
be a big airbnb guy uh but
more now that we go on the road the
hotels are better well i don't want to
see anyone's [ __ ] i want someone to come
in make my bed if i want it i mean i
don't actually like them coming in
because i have 80d and then i always
like if i can't find my ipad i don't
want to like
accuse someone you know what i mean
i could easily have just like slipped it
somewhere in between the bed that i'll
never find it tackling some made in the
lobby i just never want to falsely
accuse someone so i just say stay out
yeah but at my last i was just in
arizona in phoenix and they didn't have
a do not disturb
what they didn't i just couldn't find
one i could have just asked for one but
i couldn't forget it
yeah no i should've i was thinking about
in lipstick or something
[ __ ]
i went out to uh lunch with my aunt my
both my aunt's out there and i then
neither of them talk to each other very
awkward she said aunts by the way yeah
it's weird oh i know
i say orange now too i don't say orange
i don't know orange
instead of uh instead of water
water wow i don't know what's going on
you've changed i mean
you need to get down to south philly
get straightened out get a cheesesteak
get your head on right there's rumors i
might be doing a uh thanksgiving show
there but i don't know really but
nothing's nothing's set
interesting what is the origin story of
andy letterman lay it on me i believe
you're from
i'm from cheltenham yeah so lay it on us
give us give us the whole the whole
rundown all right i'm a twin
what
oh also wait before we do this before i
don't like this [ __ ] caroline's this
weekend please come to [ __ ]
caroline's this weekend before i forget
caroline's out there baby okay
all right i so i was i'm a i have a twin
brother max okay his name is actually
where ann and matthew is how we were
born
but we're annie and max now why is that
his nickname he well he got it changed
legally he just got he got called mad
max in kindergarten and then he just i
remember exactly where we were when it
happened we're in the after school
program at our quaker school there's a
lot to talk about yes and uh germany
cool we went or no way into green street
friends school across from germantown
friends okay in germantown that's a mix
you might have a look at my bees maybe
some christmas who said mix and that is
germantown where the families were mixed
yeah it's uh yeah germantown is a very
specific part of it very very like
yeah it's goofball i never grew up here
either your parents are either two
lesbians
one's black one's white yeah but you are
like you are mixed up there okay not a
traditional looking family yeah
homogenized but they had okay so our at
our elementary school there was this
this
um
house right next to it that these like
really white trash people lived in like
when i say white trash like they there
was a pile of trash and the kids would
emerge and you couldn't tell it was like
yeah moving trash like dirty you know
because they're just like so dirty like
that like deliveries they wake up in the
morning and put a dirty t-shirt and they
didn't go to school they were like
always there so we would just be like
going like from one class the other
walking to the um the playground and
then these like little like dirty white
kids would just be like
and once my brother left his bag he like
went inside we just all have atd he left
his bag and went inside to pee or
something
and they
he someone stole his bag and he couldn't
find it and then he saw it like dumped
out in their yard
rummaged through it i don't know what
the hell you're talking about but you
bring it out of here right now ain't no
one got your bag here but we were that
family i realized we were that family on
our street like we were the trashy
family on the block we didn't have trash
in the in the
in the backyard or anything but we were
we were garbage like we were like the
loud door slamming our dog we never
walked our dog our dog would just go out
oh and then
you had a loose dog policy growing up oh
[ __ ] to the point where when people
would bring the dog back to be nice
we'd be like uh
we let her out he was going for a walk
someone let pinky out like someone would
just go let her out and then she would
go neighbors hated it because she would
like [ __ ] and their stuff i would be
shooting i would be right in like the
townships and stuff yeah but it was my
family just and i realized that's
literally how they raised us
they raised us the same way like the dog
they're just like let them out they'll
come back when they're hungry that's
nuts and that's why i'm a comedian break
this down for me what did you what did
your dad do what did your mom do my dad
worked at the uh he was a treasurer at
the university of pennsylvania okay so
there's some money there's some money
involved but my mom my mom had a bunch
of different jobs so my mom like never
really had like she was
not a stay-at-home mom she was like a
sort of a round mom like she would do
like
she just like one job she had was she
worked at wxpn the radio station radio
station dj
no she was she did like their newsletter
she would interview different acts and
stuff but she didn't really listen to
music so that was awesome so she could
do whatever she wanted your dad was she
could my dad was bringing in
a nice house nice house yeah you were
the trashy ones in the neighborhood it
was here's the thing my dad came from a
trash he was from that's what it is yeah
so my dad it's not money i would say my
dad's like my mom's from like a nice
area in upstate new york and my dad
popped out of a tuna can
so my dad he's just incredibly smart
he's got 80d he doesn't get his work
done he's defiant he's like you know
where he goes
he went to um
risd first rhode island school of design
no no not risd what's the one that's the
engineering mit no no but with an r
rhode island school of no it's not rhode
island engineering some engine
what not risd [ __ ] um i don't know
risd rhode island school of design isn't
no that's not what i mean but it's uh uh
he went to rensselaer poly technical
institute what yeah that's it damn rpi
rpi rpi i went to rpi this sounds
chi-ish
but it's so funny
i was asking him because he's not like
he's not an engineer like an engineer's
brain engineers are very specific yeah
it's about yes yeah it's funny charlie
yeah well i guess i mean i don't know i
i think he charmed his way into this job
like he shouldn't have had this job
was he there for a long time he was
there for a long time but he got to
retire early which i don't know if
that's good or bad yeah get out of here
hey letterman kick rocks they still live
in that house or if they move they moved
they're in win more now okay so they
didn't move far all right they're close
what was the name of the street in
cheltenham um i lived on glenview avenue
1 30 glenview sounds nice it's not bad
it was beautiful glenview ave sounds
really nice we lived right behind uh tw
park so we had a park right near us okay
it was really it was a nice so it wasn't
upbringing we had a beautiful place
would your pop take care of the property
would he cut the grass and [ __ ] like
that no no no no you had someone do it
no but next door we had the berks which
were there were three girls or no two
girls and like four boys i think
they had six kids your age catholic no
well matt was
the youngest was in between my brother's
ages and i don't i think they shared him
so my twin brother i have an older
brother who's um three years older so
matt was like somewhere in between he
was like a year older okay i don't
remember if he was timmy's friend or
max's friend but
then it went up and it was like a bunch
of hot
catholic boys that played
sports they look good all right they're
all like coaches now dads like they're
all doing good but
but one the oldest one jimmy lived at
home and was the guy that did all the
lawns in the neighborhood oh in the
neighborhood it was a local operation
that's pretty good all right so you
weren't that's not like the the weeds
were overgrown in there no no we looked
fine but i'm just saying they like
through parties like they you know like
they let us have like kegs and stuff
like we are that type of trash oh loud
screaming well your parents would let
you throw
yeah underage really
well yeah yeah wow nice yeah well that's
always a good time yeah talk about
rolling the dice i mean it's not the
best it's not the best way to raise a
kid but it's a good [ __ ] time let's
just say i got molested a lot they they
let me correct i got molested quite a
few times but but it worked out i'm a
comedian yeah they look good wouldn't i
wouldn't trade any of the json
i would never give that just back
huh okay all right so okay so
twin brother max was okay so max came
out first i came out feet first
afterwards like
kicked his ass out jesus you came out
first i came up first then i was in an
incubator which i think could be
girls goes dude i can tell she's a twin
she came out reversed on an incubator he
comes out i think i got i'm always like
maybe i got molested that like the i was
like
i thought they spin you if you're coming
out feet first don't they spin you
around i don't think they could no they
pulled my ass out like
and then i i you know i got some of the
[ __ ] juice in there and then i had to
be in an incubator
my dad said he felt guilty because i was
like all healthy in the icu and all the
other babies
like see-through you're just warming up
i was like my skin's actually matte
i'm just getting a base going
and you have one older brother i have
one older brother how many years older
is he he's like two and a half years all
right so you guys were all in high
school together yeah but i went to
chelsea i went to craft field okay i
went to the juvenile delinquent school
you did wait you went why we'll get to
this back it up a little bit my parents
are idiots
when we left you you were a nice friends
school i went to the main street friends
school
i mean i was a private school they had
to pay for that yeah they paid for that
okay and my school so my teacher
i definitely
i was like good at heart but i had some
i did have some emotional problems i was
an angry kid my dad was angry i learned
to be angry for my dad sure so i would
get like i didn't learn to like manage
my emotions until like probably last
year sometimes i'm still i'm still
working on it sometimes but um yeah
we're both crazy like i wasn't
i wasn't like a bad kid but i did like
throw my glasses case at my teacher's
head once do you know what i mean like
yeah that's a bad kid in the friend
school but not like i wasn't like the
case
yeah 20 am then what defines a [ __ ]
bad kid in your head knocking over banks
and [ __ ] but it was it was more out of
like he told me to relax like it was a
trigger moment you know rather than like
people hate that when you tell them to
relax
it really drive me crazy you tell me to
relax i will lose it that teacher came
to see me when i did uh punchline
really yeah
do you remember you throwing the glasses
at him wait i don't think that's
something
is this grade school this was fifth
grade a grade school teacher came he's
my only good teacher dude i'm like thank
you for not diddling me i really
appreciate that he's a good guy he
married my first grade teacher cindy we
called our teachers by their first names
and at quaker school yeah that always
freezes which by the way
quaker school it's fine when i went to
my high school and was the juvenile and
we called them by their first names that
was literally like
yeah you did that as like you guys
looked at each other as like peers you
know what i mean yeah it was bad
and let's just say they appeared at us
[Laughter]
all right so did you get kicked out of
this friends school i did not get kicked
out of the front school we wanted to
come to high school we left in sixth
grade we went to
uh
uh to cedar brook or to ep to elkins
park and then to cedar brook so you were
then in the public schools we did public
school for a couple years i was smoking
cigarettes i was being a little bit bad
right we're talking seventh eighth grade
you're smoking sick yeah we're talking
newports we're talking more blights
p-funks what are we doing newport lights
newport lights right holy that's pretty
that's pretty cute i've never even heard
of anybody
newport lights but yeah no i yeah
so
i was doing a little bit of that and i
was getting into some trouble you know i
had a friend who
i mean they're all like diagnosed
bipolar now like all my friends sure
all like
they got the diagnosis now but they were
fun what'd you get in trouble for
so they got in trouble they were coming
to pick me up so we met these dudes we
would sneak out of her house she lived
in what pick you up she moves quick this
one these stories i'll be here hold on
so now okay so now i'm in like i skipped
eighth grade
i'm trying to think of when this was
wait why did you skip eighth grade
because i went to the juvenile
delinquent school and they didn't it
wasn't a real school they were just like
whatever is going to get her horny
enough to [ __ ] us um
no they i just they had an upper school
and a they had a middle a lower school
and an upper school okay and so they
started at like sixth grade i think and
they went up to
so for your eighth grade you should have
been in the school you were in but you
went to this but i still don't get why
you want to send me to this place
i didn't it was like the it was like win
code academy it was like it was a an
alternative so it was for like the kids
to get kicked out
you wouldn't give me like sick breaks
yeah but you were never kidding
yes
i never got kicked out of a school your
parents were just like where can they're
like this seems fun jesus i was like
pillows instead of chairs
this is awesome
i was 14 they sent me there but i don't
know if i'd been getting in trouble like
the summer before that or after i can't
remember
but um
i started to be really bad once i was
hanging out with the true young
criminals no you didn't stay there
overnight you you would go back and
forth for me no i didn't stay there
overnight but i did there was a teacher
that convinced my parents to let me stay
overnight which is why i made it
what you had a teacher convinced my
teachers convinced my parents that when
i was
16 to stay over there 15 i can't
remember 15 or 16. what and it did end
up in court guys what yes i got jackson
pollock on my leg by my art teacher
god holy damn it
took him to court nice
got him like probate i mean nothing
happened yeah it's so bad it's so it's
so bonkers what about the civil side
what's the deal what i don't know the
civil statement you didn't fill them up
no my parents like i forgive my parents
but my parents
this is serious [ __ ] here i know this
was so [ __ ] long ago too it's like
you know and your brain doesn't like
always remember everything you know
like let some things go of course of
course
i came to consciousness at like 28. i
yeah i'm just figuring it out i'm like
i'm doing like hypnosis to try to like
reprogram a lot of people holy [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] heavy so yeah so i go
i go to i went to court and then
is this in is this this was in high
school this is real time did they yank
you out of there once this incident
happened uh-uh they kept did you go home
and say hey this i graduated soon after
that apparently i didn't need many
requisites once i how old are you
graduating i graduated i was 16 yeah
wait then go to the rest of high school
no no i graduated high school at 16. and
then i went to yeah i took a year off
and then i went to college
at this school
timeline is all over none of this is
making sense it's not a real school but
my parents like did some settlement
i gotta say i'm looking at the website
they're leaving out some testimonials
where does your brother know they are
probably sweating me so hard right now
where did your brother go successful my
brother went to cheltenham my brothers
went to public school but your parents
for some reason sent you to the school
yeah i think i was like pmsing they
didn't understand what's going on
they're like our daughter's crazy
wow she's not like our sons
yeah but so i ended up going i mean
everything was [ __ ] crazy
but okay no ask questions yeah what was
some of them
it's great what were some of the crimes
you were committing or like the mischief
you were getting into you said you had
these bad friends they came we would
like steal cars oh that was like bars
come on but like the only thing i was
always really my friends were bad my
friends i was the lookout wow you know
my friends were really bad but i would
like we would still like we stole our
friend hadley's car like it wasn't like
sure are these kids knocking over her
are these kids from your neighborhood
no they're from all over okay all over
shut up the shutdown area no they're all
they're all over the city that's bad
when you're mixing with that
neighborhood all over different places
everyone lives somewhere else yeah
that's bad one guy uh everybody should
stay in their own school district john
farley
he used to pick me up and he lived in my
neighborhood
[Laughter]
i wonder where we go back to philly i
don't want john farley coming in but
john barley is cool i i wonder where
he's at i want to leave his name in he
used to pick you up what he used to pick
me up in his um jeep and he would blast
like icp
but he's so he lived in my neighborhood
ish and he would pick me up but it
wasn't
what kind of g are we talking cherokee
grand cherokee wrangler no he had like
the
one with no doors he had the horse if
you're blasting
their catalogue i don't know if that
made the greatest hits gang you don't
want to spend time in a in a mattress
store like a bozo these days you don't
want to pick up a mattress that you
don't really know how it's going to feel
or if it's going to if it's going to be
your type of mattress something you need
well helix has it all taken care of for
you you go on helix you fill up the
questionnaire you find out what kind of
bed you like to sleep in and they match
you if you sleep hot if you sleep cold
if you sleep fat like me if you're a big
guy they got big guys they have big guy
sizes you got big guy beds they're the
best uh best in the biz uh my wife and i
took the helix quiz and they were nice
enough to send us a mattress baby best
matches i ever had in my life first like
grown up adult mattress if you're in the
market sign up take the quiz we got
match with the twilight model got a
queen so good i think we're gonna
upgrade to a king now i've done a
sleepover over there
it's nice that's the first i'm hearing
about this just got to say
uh guys there's a huge upgrade to the
life the sleep is better it's it's it's
made for you you know what i mean it's
perfect for you so if you're looking for
a mattress take the quick quiz uh you're
they'll order the mattress that's
matched to you comes right to your door
shipped free uh you don't ever have to
go to the mattress store again like a
bozo like the big man said uh don't take
my word for it go to the website and
also they've been ranked number one best
overall mattress pick for 2020 by gq and
wired magazine i mean what are we doing
just go to helix sleep.com garbage like
i said take the two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you uh with a
customized mattress they'll give you the
best sleep of your life 10 year warranty
on this thing nice you try it out for
100 nights risk-free look at that you'll
even pick it up if you don't love it but
i'm telling you you will here it is the
big call to action baby helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix
sleeps.com garbage that's helixly.com
garbage for up to 200. and two free
pillows hey kippy what's up raycon
wireless earbuds i've heard about them
just got a fresh pack i know absolutely
fantastic i haven't had a pair of
earbuds in a long time listen for the
listener this bozo's just been living
his life for years without without
headphones people are giving me looks on
the subway now things are opening back
up you're going to be around people you
got to have your rakons on you
get your tunes going best way to listen
100 kippy tell what they need to know uh
it's i mean these things are top-notch
raycons have a 32-hour battery life so
you can listen to what you want when you
want for a really long time we're
talking 32 hours not 24 hours not 30 out
32 hours it's a lot of tunes baby uh and
the best thing is they started half the
price of other premium audio brands but
they sound just as good also comes with
a 45-day happiness guarantee there you
go who doesn't like to be happy there
you go we all could use a little
happiness standing behind the product i
like that and raycon's guaranteeing us
uh so you really can't lose give them a
try you'll see what we mean
um also you can create your own
soundtrack with raycon right now are you
garbage listeners can get up to can get
15 percent off the raycon order at buy
raycon dot com slash garbage they're
already half the price and now they're
giving you a 15 discount great credit i
don't even know what these guys know
what they're doing that's great craig
giving away the store
uh that's buy raycon.com garbage to save
15 on ray cons one more time guys get
out your phone throw it in the browser
write it down tell a friend buy
raycon.com garbage now back to the show
so you graduate 16. your brother's still
in high school yeah
then what'd you do what do you do with
six i went to i did a trip to central
america by yourself no i went with like
a group of people and we did like an
organization or like yeah i was like i
don't know where my parents found this
this was
the art teacher was like
i i don't know what happened to him in
between that but i did talk about this
on mark martin i i want to sorry i put
it but there's so many i have so many
questions where did you sleep at the
school was there a place to sleep no
their house
oh my god their house they set up a room
for me and my friend to stay there so we
could get ready for college
they got us ready for parks jesus christ
they got us ready for community college
that's [ __ ] crazy man wow okay i
forgive my parents i forgive my parents
i forgive my parents
i mean they didn't know they didn't know
how do they not i don't [ __ ] know
sure
no but it was crazy it was like how many
times a week do you floss that's what
that's what i was coming to [ __ ] play
with i do floss a lot now still blood
not enough really yeah it's tough man
like an onion in this character
letterman's all over the road down to
south america central america central
america i went for like three months and
then i did like a thing in hawaii too
where i worked with dolphins
really they found some like it was
called this is when you're a miner this
is like so insane i know i could have
been sold into sex trafficking so easily
they also sent me to jersey city for
like a modeling agency when i was 15.
my parents and i almost like i was
getting chased by a six foot eight drag
queen named mahogany for my life like i
was running i was like call that cops i
was like hiding behind cars and [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
i've run for my life a lot what the [ __ ]
this makes me sad i don't like that
don't be sad look at me now you're
fantastic this is why you got to keep
your dog on a
to leash dog people this is for real
i'm mad at your parents
was the thing in central i like how your
mom i like how your parents said you
were modeling thing in jersey city like
not even new york it wasn't even
they're like listen we can't be paying a
toll for the tunnel she's okay in jersey
you're gonna start in delaware where
they're waiting you know what it is
they're just really like trusting so if
people like can lie to their face really
easy and be like we'll take great care
of her and they're like great was
central america okay it was great it was
fun all right yeah our parents weren't
there what about
hawaii hawaii was good hawaii was that
for a month trained the dolphins that
was really fun and then you come back
now you're what's up i come back i'm 17
i start working with kids with special
needs that's i started working at a
summer camp nice okay you're living at
home uh-huh oh yeah i'm living at home
and then i went to and then after that
summer when i worked at easter seals i
then went to
the college of santa fe in new mexico
all right now we go now we're getting to
some some normal ground we're coming out
four-year institutions you took us to
college to get something to relate on
well the college is now the college has
has since been gone out of business of
course it has
then it came back of course
then it came back so the college went
out of business the way colleges can
dissolve yeah
then it
it took a sabbatical holy [ __ ] so okay
so the college so the college was the
college of santa fe when i went to it
okay then and i had all these
incompletes because i never did my work
i was like still cutting and you
graduated yeah i wanted to ask you like
what you what was your gpa but did this
school even have one the school no i
don't think that great i honestly don't
think that how many years are you
actually at the high school
uh it wasn't four two what the [ __ ] two
or three it's just happening in my
backyard i don't like this
dude i've gotten so many people in
trouble though i'm good i'm good at
getting people in trouble jesus christ
not in like a me too in like a real get
it done way like uh i can tell you he
said you said it things ended in court
that's pretty heavy but then he didn't
really not much happened because oh also
here's where the real betrayal i mean
the betrayal keeps going his
lawyer was my softball coach the teacher
was my softball court that seems like a
conflict of interest i know he's not
[ __ ] up but so then he got off because
he was like you weren't still on the
team were you no
i quit i broke my foot and stopped doing
sports and started smoking cigarettes
instead
but like car accident
you were at the age where you would have
been on the softball team right i was in
softball in middle school and then and i
played on the boys baseball team to get
my mom's attention
she played on the boys baseball because
she was like your mom was the boys
baseball team coach
dude what the [ __ ]
no she traded me to a different team too
and that's just
i was like mom hang out with me and she
was like get out [ __ ]
like i'm the only girl in this team my
mom was like cause she'd always when i
was growing up my mom was like my mom's
she's saying this like it's like it's
your mom was the head coach of the
baseball team she was the president of
the little league for a little bit older
little league
geez she's got a lot to prove
uh did your college change its name to
the santa fe university of art and
design and then i went out of business
again it did in 2018. yep
it sure did now it's called chili's
then it burned down then the barracks
burned down
the barracks yeah there were barracks
they're called
the psychology department was like in
old barracks and the the
mental institution i think the cafeteria
was in um
the old morgue
that's not a school this is this is
[Laughter]
was actually a great school and the
teachers i don't know anything about it
any but it was not the teachers were
like so good but they there was a uh
president that embezzled
this guy at lombardi embezzled money
well what would you think it was ivy
league the [ __ ] you're looking at me for
it it was a liberal arts school the
barracks burned down did you not hear
that i went there barracks burned down
the barracks
i like that school though i think i've
got i got good memories of that school
frank corral my old professor did you
play baseball there i didn't have sports
we didn't even have to take math
did you take the sats i did i took them
untimed with no one watching me in my
advisor's office on a couch taking naps
and [ __ ] okay and what'd you get
uh
11
something that's not bad that's good
yeah for having seemingly zero education
no i have a seventh grade i've gone to
peter pan high school
this is crazy
i mean we sat down with over a hundred
people and insane backstories this is
nuts this should have been stopped at
some point wait can i tell you though
right no i did stop it i stopped it
myself but i but here's the thing that's
so funny i didn't realize until like
three years ago that everyone didn't
have this type of story your brothers
didn't even have this i know it's true
it's true you didn't even look down the
hallway
where did your brother go to school
let's use that as where did they go to
college where'd your twin go he went to
um
what is it called it's in boston
northeastern what
okay you want to know my twenty what do
you do for a living now he is look him
up look up max letterman led our man
he is
a two-time emmy award-winning sports
television producer look at that there
you go
shout out to max oh my god if you google
him i come up
yeah is that him right yeah
wow max letterman yeah
there you go yeah good looking awesome
good looking kid it's so funny that if
you google image my brother i come up
people think if you google a husband too
no really comes up cause i did the eat
out symbol in a picture with him think
he was funny and now everyone thinks i'm
dating him
we also accidentally got like engagement
photos
damn that was that was [ __ ]
what is that is that that was thunder
yeah wait you got engagement photos with
your brother accidentally because i was
working
i lived in santa fe so i lived in santa
fe for eight years and part of one of my
jobs i had a lot of jobs there i was uh
um so i can't wait to hear this resume
no you're gonna like it so you just
when you got out there you stayed well i
didn't graduate i took a long time to
graduate eric's birthday i finally lost
all of her stuff
we gotta wait for
[Laughter]
i did eventually graduate but i had all
these incompletes because i learned from
my dad how to like you work the system i
never did any of my work but my teachers
always really liked me so they'd be like
we'll give you an incomplete finish this
later
who's floating this bill by the way your
parent
i had a grandfather my mom's father no
my no it was expensive really my my
mom's father when he died he left his
money he had a lot of money so he left
his college buddy he worked um
something in finance
in new york in the city but here in
school he left us like i think he left
us like
i don't know how much it was but it was
enough to cover
like seven of the years do you know what
i mean like it was enough to cover but i
was 15 years old i wasn't in it fully
you know like i was like waitressing
bartending and stuff and like i would
take like semesters off i got you i was
drinking a lot i didn't quit drinking
times 20 or i did quit drinking at 25. i
don't know why i'm looking at you like
you don't drink sure maybe someday soon
but um
[Music]
yeah no my so this is what i did in
santa fe i was a nanny a go-go dancer a
um get the check please i did like a
special
i was like a special ed
because i wasn't like a stripper yeah i
know i wasn't it was the way that job
happened was like burlesque
no it was so there was one club in santa
fe that was called swig it was owned by
these two gay guys a couple so it was
like a tiny bit of a gay club but not
really because it was the only club in
santa fe gotcha so it was like i think
maybe if there had been another club
they would have made it like fully gay
but
um
but it was they had three podiums down
in the bottom in the basement area
and they would have like me i just was
there drunk one night and the i was
friends with the
the um dj manager and she was like
she was like i'll give you 50 bucks to
dance and i was like okay and i was
drunk i'm not even like a confident
dancer in any way but i was wasted so i
was like sure still in the robot yeah i
was like out there doing everything i
could and then she was like hey they
want to hire you for 50 bucks an hour to
come back and do this like every
saturday and i'm like 50 bucks an hour
is great right so i'm like that's
awesome so i would just wear like
knee-high boots and like a short skirt
and like
body top and i would just like be up
there but i didn't have rhythm or
anything so people would come up and try
to dance i couldn't like
dance with other like it's like this
like it was a very like tense like if
anything happened i was thrown off my
rhythm
but nobody looked at me so it would be
the podium would usually there was like
usually like a gay guy or there was a um
a
drag queen
brandy that would come in okay uh they
and then they hired like a real stripper
and then me she was a bad dancer but she
had like big fake tits and wear pasties
and would be getting tips in her
g-string and stuff and i was like that
made it weird for me i like stopped
working there because i was like i don't
want them touching me yeah yeah yeah i
was just sort of to like get other
people to dance but it was a weird i
remember being wasted and like going
into the owner's office and being like
they're objectifying me and he was like
well yeah and he's like also he's like
you don't have to come here like we
don't care if you come back like yeah
yeah it's like we're not we don't need
you to like but i would always be like
crying i had like these um
the little like chicken cutlet things to
make me look like i had boobs and i'd be
sweating and they'd be like sliding up
and
i would just like my knees hurt i wasn't
gonna
i'd fall off the dance i got her elbow
wrapped i really was i was like
shots in your knees
no i didn't have health insurance you
got an orange slice who's the girl
wearing batting gloves no but i really
honestly this is very accurate
trying to dance in tim's but i was just
crying and oh my god it was funny though
what other jobs okay
i was a nanny while i was a go get
answers so there was a lot of glitter in
my life
and then i would like be i would just i
would show up to their house just with
like
like day yeah just so ridiculous i was
an innkeeper at a bed and breakfast i
was a bartender a waitress and
what else did i do there
um i worked with the special ed at the
high school for a little bit that was
nice that's good what kind of uh
did you gotta go listen
if you got a disability i'm into it come
to my shows at caroline's my
audience i'm manifesting like this
audience people are missing limbs like i
signed some guys tricky out of me hole
the other day
no it's so awesome i'm like bring your
nub up here dude i'm i got a sharpie
really oh i love it wow that's my
biggest fear what having the voice box
thing oh [ __ ] i thought you were saying
being around people with it
that's sad i lose my appetite you have
another hole to try to [ __ ] you know
um
flexible enough to stick your dick in
that ain't gonna happen that ain't gonna
happen but um
i had a lot of jobs there was all i'm
saying but anyway so i
i don't know where am i at with the
college of santa fe uh it was a good
school bunch of weird jobs bunch of
weird job where did you what were the
restaurants you would bartender and
waitress and would it be like dive bars
or would it be like uh applebee's
popular dive bars so it would be like i
worked at this place called um
yeah good places cool places like i'm
i'm not going to get your order right
but i'm going to be like fun you're
going to like me you're going to tip me
well we're going to have a good
experience you know what i mean but i
can't have the pressure of like
memorizing specials or you thinking
you're gonna get like the right
temperature of your steak you know what
i mean like
it's gonna be fun we're gonna be
drinking we're gonna be doing shots it's
gonna be a good time it's that type of
thing okay i like it but i used to make
a lot i remember i used to always go i'd
be like
i would say uh
i would slap the bill down and i'd be
like anything less than 50 is an insult
and that would give me 50 a lot of times
really yeah
they liked me thought
i'm going to do a show in santa fe and
it's going to [ __ ] sell out hard
because i made like a lot of friends i
was always collecting people and then
when i lived in new york i used to
produce shows and i had my mailing list
was like so long i wish i still had it
because i want those people to come out
and see me i know
i want them to come see me uh
i caroline's because they all used to
come see me just do shows at this
restaurant
yeah what restaurant it was called life
cafe it went out of business everything
i taught you disappears
oh this is the last episode of the box
sorry
we had a good run chelsea lately that
that got canceled after i was on it let
me ask you let's give it a little
argument let's play a couple a couple of
games here um a couple of couple of
questions i'd like to know a couple of
things about now now where do you live
what
you have an apartment you have a house
what's the situation now i have an
apartment you're doing pretty well don't
do it
well this is new because three years ago
or four years ago i remember standing
outside the comedy store i'm looking at
rogan's 14th car i am living out of my
car for the second time i'm like what
kind of car
uh i had a prius like one of those
little ones the prius you were legit
living out of it yes legit sleeping in
it some night show like that like when i
didn't call people in time
anyway so um i'm looking at
and i just gone through a breakup so
this was my second time being in the car
and then my friend mike o'dare let me
stay with him but
it was just like this is three years ago
uh-huh damn and so well when i go
through a breakup i go you can have it
all by i'm like take it see ya i'm out
um
i usually move to the other coast but i
was down with new york
the prius wasn't gonna make it there
wasn't enough charging i like to have a
car to sleep in if i need to but so um
[Music]
i uh
was out in the parking lot with joe and
i was like how is it that you have like
13 cars and i'm living in mine
he's like you live in your car he's like
oh my god and he just like pulled out
this makes him sound like a dick but it
was actually really funny but he pulled
out like a wad of hundreds and he was
like i just want you know this means
nothing to me just like hand me 300 and
there was like a run of like two or
three months where every time you'd see
me he'd just come high five me hundreds
that's awesome i mean he was paying my
[ __ ] rent but he was also would laugh
in my face and i'd be like this is the
funniest bit let's keep this up yeah
yeah that was a great bit this is great
but it was great and then he stopped
doing which was good too because i was
like i don't want like handouts and
stuff like that and so but he was like
start a podcast come on we'll promote it
all that stuff he's like you should not
be
but it was like i realized over the
pandemic over the break spring break um
it was so fun 2020
um santa fe you it was really honestly
this pandemic was not bad didn't your
podcast kind of take off you blew up in
the painting it's like i felt bad
because like we've said it before but
like people were like i don't know what
we're gonna do and meanwhile we're like
we're making more money
i literally learned to survive in that
pandemic for real but so um
i started i have a solo podcast that i'm
bringing back but i stopped doing it
when i started doing trash tuesday
because it was like
we moved but we moved apartments but so
i was living in the pandemic i finally
had found an apartment for 1600 bucks it
was a one bedroom and i was like using
my spot money from the comedy store to
pay for it and just like really really
really scraping by
and um
and then i started dating my boyfriend
right before the uh coveted hit and i
was just he's 11 years younger than me
he worked at the comedy store he was
like worked in the basement basement
todd and i was just like trying to hook
up with him but he's from jersey he's
just like it was just a little bit
things were like kind of it just he was
a match but i was like he's so [ __ ]
what am i gonna do with this kid yeah
and um so i was gonna
just dump the [ __ ] i mean i was like
dude i'll hook up with you a couple
times then you gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here and then the pandemic hit like it
was like like a month before that we
were hooking up and i was like like if
you leave i'll die yeah yeah and then so
now don't leave me i was like
what are you gonna do you need me but
then he blew up in the pandemic too oh
baseball shut out he started um he
started his own business and now he's
like working as an editor on a
story producer on a netflix show and
he's editing awesome he does all of
whitney's like uh clips fantastic right
yeah he's just coming but you it was
your apartment you have i had the
apartment and then he moved in so then i
was like all right at least i have
someone paying half the rent great there
you go and then they started so they
sold the building right before the
pandemic to like a big company and the
big company
um got rid of the i had a creepy
landlord that used to try to kiss me in
the mouth and stuff [ __ ] annoying man
he was i have a joke about it
i have a joke about it but he used to
like she's a creep magnet this one no i
really um i know i picked oh yeah you
know what they call it being hot
hot with loose boundaries it's called
you uglies out there well you know what
it is you know what it is i was trying
to kiss you nobody told me i was cute
but i was cute so i didn't know so i was
wandering around not realizing that i
was like attractive to people thinking i
was like ugly and like a boy yeah and i
was like
i'm like do all boys get
poked this much
wow
but um
anyway
yeah so
you're in a place now so but we okay so
we're living in this place they sold it
to a new company
the company is like offering everyone
buyouts except me because everyone else
had lived there for a long time
at this point i'm looking for we had a
nice quiet dinner and fell asleep that's
never going to happen i'm open for a
happy ending
well no it is happening
everything's great everything's
absolutely perfect and everything's
happened exactly the way it's supposed
to happen and i feel like
absolutely grateful for every load that
i didn't that was illegal
that was dropped on my body
as a kid
i like the sentiment behind there you go
of course no no i really like honestly
like i do feel like that's what i love
about having
being able to do comedy and like connect
with people it's like i mean we are all
[ __ ] up you guys know this is what
your podcast
and i don't want to like i never want to
like be too on the nose because that's
not funny but it's like it really is
like kind of
amazing that we get to do this
oh no it's so yeah every day every day
we think the same thing
i'm like so grateful and i try to i'm
like i don't want to be like
kyle ceaseless [ __ ] do you know who
kyle c says he was the comic that turned
into like a motivational motivational
speaker but i mean it's like we are like
it's such a i'm just really [ __ ]
can't believe it but anyway
so i have no i don't feel bad about any
of this [ __ ] at all i worked through all
that trauma i did so much work on that i
mean i i repressed it worked on it you
know like it all came out i had like a
couple years i was screaming yeah yeah
well that's the thing as you get older
too it's a thing it's like perspective
you know if you look back on it as you
get older differently than you did in
your 20s or something well it's like you
i don't know what the term is for it but
like what i said earlier where it's like
i didn't realize that everyone hadn't
gone through this [ __ ] so then when i
realized it and i was like unpacking
that i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i
was like filled with rage i was so mad
at my parents i used to call my parents
and be like [ __ ] you like yeah you got
me right like [ __ ] like that and they're
just like we're sorry
yeah or like not really be able to say
sorry for whatever reason they're going
through but then when i realized like
they're human beings and they just
[ __ ] didn't understand of course yeah
yeah they would never do that now if
they knew and like thank god they did it
because it gave me a little
little edge yeah sticky ass you got a
little spunk i got a little
no pun intense yeah that's great i got a
little skunk
but anyway so we're in i'm in this
apartment
they start doing construction around the
apartment and i keep thinking i'm gonna
get a buyout or something so i'm like
waiting in this apartment like i need
this money
this is darn covered i'm like [ __ ] i'm
like this is insane i'm not making any
money i'm like what should i do so
trashy hoping for a buyout yeah
excellent here last man standing fingers
i'm like maybe give me some cage well
they're asking everyone else but
everyone else had lived there for 20
years so their rent was like 20 bucks so
they were like i i was like their mo
their cash count 1600. so anyway so they
ended up um
like [ __ ] what they're saying they're
gonna buy us out not and i was like
all right whatever i got an ulcer like
they're doing construction in every
apartment around us so it was just like
two months i mean i was in hell you
couldn't leave your [ __ ] apartment it
was so like criminal but anyway so then
we get our vaccines we go to see our
families this is as recent as the
vaccines okay so i'm like i'm broke i
don't have anything i start i find this
guy's podcast this guy named jim fortin
and i started like doing ice i just
decided to pay for this program that he
does that was like so ex more expensive
than anything i paid for but i was like
i'm just gonna like take a leap of faith
i think this guy's like i love his
podcast i love what he says and his is
all about
his take on life and his philosophy and
his work that he does is about like
conscious subconscious reprogramming
sure of course and um
but he also like his brother-in-law's a
shaman so he's got some like really like
spiritual hippie [ __ ] too but so i liked
his pockets i was like i'm just gonna
take this [ __ ] course like they were
you were able to pay like per month i
was like [ __ ] i'm gonna do it
and um so i was doing that course and i
was starting to kind of get that that i
had these beliefs about myself that i
don't have money so i was like i'm trash
like if you look at like my family like
my dad made a lot of money but
we still kind of lived like a trashy
life you know my family was the same way
we were like and then they spent all the
money and had money again and then no
money yeah
yeah trash it was like new money [ __ ]
and it's kind of like the way that you
the the how you're raised with money is
like how you live your life through it
so it was like i was thinking the way my
family was always was it would be like
we don't have any money here's the 20.
so it was like very like scary and then
also like do we have money or not i
can't tell you
and it's like we had more money than a
lot of our friends growing up and then
we and then i like went to college and
everyone had more money than us so it
was like it was just a weird it was just
a it was a confusing thing and i didn't
really understand it and so anyway so i
realized i kept moving back into my car
i'm like this is [ __ ] so weird i'm
like i do the same thing as all these
you're in this multi millionaires like
my friends are like so [ __ ] rich like
what is going on
and so i started doing that program and
we go to see our family
after we get our vaccine and we come
back and there's even more construction
like the building is like completely
boarded up they took away our parking
our laundry like all this stuff and i
just looked at my boyfriend and i was
like we're moving out in the next two
days like we're done i don't care how we
do it and i had probably like
1400 in my bank account
i go to my mailbox there's a letter from
the irs i'm like holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
do i owe like what did i do yeah
and then i was like wait i'm spending
money on this program let me just like
put positive energy out and nothing i
open it up 6 000 unclaimed dollars
like when in the world has that ever
happened six thousand dollars so then i
was like we just immediately white trash
come on baby let's go immediately moved
out i caught we found a place you buy a
new car thank you
no dude i'm liking a tesla i'm doing
great but um
but it was just yeah it was like the
easiest thing in the world you got a
tesla i'm getting one yeah nice i
already i like started online yeah love
that but um well i used to say tesla
2020 and then the pandemic and i was
like tesla 2021 tesla 2021 that's great
and so yeah no so that moved out of
there so moved out of there now i live
um i live i do live in an apartment but
i live near the beach and
there's security in my apartment
building so there's no homeless people
can come in and stab us that's nice
which our old neighborhood was getting
so stabby it's like so crazy there's so
much math oh yes
that you guys live together in this
place yeah we live together in this
place we got a puppy nice we live with
our dog and then so we moved into a put
it on a leash
yes yes we're very good
he's very well behaved it's so funny my
parents are like you have such a good
dog i'm like they all start good you
know that right yeah you train them to
be bad yeah yeah yeah you had to teach
them not like you got a bad one yeah we
got an adorable little puppy but so he's
a year now
so we moved into this new place
it's a one bedroom and now we realize we
need a bigger place so now we're moving
at the end of the month into a
two-bedroom loft look by the beach
in the same complex in the same place
and they have a plug-in for tesla's in
the parking garage look at that that's
classy though talk about coming full at
all yeah so now i'm going to bring my
solo podcast back because now i have an
extra room to make it to my studio she
got studio
do you feel that you have a lot of the
habits that your parents had when you
when you were growing up or do you feel
like you've rejected them
and and do your own thing i have been
noticing more and more like becoming my
parents but i instead of choosing to
make it be like um becoming my mother
i'm actually really
like touched by it and i really love it
because i figure my parents my mom's 70
my dad's 80. it's like when they go
that's going to be my tie to them it's
like going to be their like those little
things that i do that they did but it's
like stuff like this like they're all
like
everyone like loves to overeat and like
worry about food but overeat you know
and my family so
my boyfriend got like oreos and he hid
them from me up on the top of this
because i asked him like just keep them
away from me like i can't i'll eat the
whole [ __ ] thing you know what i'm
talking about
you said it sister
yes brother oh my god we're related but
um
so i he heard me like clinking around in
the kitchen and i had like a knife i was
trying to get them off the top shelf
and he came in and he was like hitting
the knife out of my hand like i was like
you know trying to kill him
and i was crying laughing because that's
like so my parents like my parents are
like
knocking each other out trying to get
icing from each other
but it's a little [ __ ] like that but i
like it i feel like that's how they're
going to be like immortal in my life
okay that's great i like it i like it
you brush your teeth in the shower
uh no i do not pee in the shower
always
yeah of course and it's better if
there's someone in there i will piss on
anyone
[Laughter]
so funny to pee on someone um
do you have name brand luggage
i just ordered nice luggage what were
you using before jessica simpson brand
from
tjf from
jj maxx yeah it's so shitty like i have
one now and it's just it's so clunky
yeah but i've been fine i've been flying
first class though really yeah
look at that you just because the
program that i'm taking i just retrained
my brain to be like i'm worth millions
of dollars like i deserve it because
it's low self-esteem that's making me
like keep feel trapped and then i'm like
i'm not doing anything that different
i'm just i just changed my attitude we
were talking we were trying to figure
out a problem
hang on so if an offer comes in you say
nah get me more
well it depends on the offer i also
right now like my you mean on the road
just in general like on the road my
guarantees i've kept kind of low because
i would rather like prove myself on the
road i don't want to ever like if
they're too big then you're gonna get
into them yeah i don't want to lose
money for anyone like i don't have any
problem with that but um
[Music]
but you know i usually will say let's
see if we can get more or see if they
can get his hair and makeup like stuff
like that like all right before you
wouldn't have said that i would never i
would be like oh my god is it okay that
i'm doing this are they sure
you know we were we were i tip fat now i
i mean not that i didn't tip fat before
but i told you like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i love doing that flying first
class yeah and like sometimes i don't
but the last time i couldn't fly first
class because if it's like
two thousand dollars i'm not gonna do it
but it's like if it's just like a little
like if it's a like
it's what's a little bit more
i paid well when i was going to surprise
my dad for his 80th birthday
um i flew first class for 1600 bucks
because i was like it felt good because
that used to be my rent that i couldn't
make just like [ __ ] six months ago
yeah and because
i was going to see my fans and i wanted
to like you know and i just like i now i
got my my frequent flyer card miles like
i'm like i now i'm just like this is
just where i live yeah you're set up
yeah you set it up a bit and it's just
they're nicer to you and it's less
people in the row and everything but
then it's also like i must don't
recommend people flying first class
because once you know it's tough to go
that's really hard i've done it once
when someone else paid for it yeah
but my coach guy that guy jim forten he
said he was like he's like i want to
recommend you guys start flying first
class
just to get yourself back and i just
started doing this yeah it's like you
put it out there it's like one of those
things and you're like oh i deserve this
and then you feel it's like you you
carry yourself i had to get over the
feeling bad for other people that don't
because it's like that's just like their
journey whatever they're gonna do but
you know i would feel like guilty before
about money like i was like oh why
should i have it and they don't it's
like
it's not like about that yeah no of
course of course they can get it what's
the bed situation king size uh queen
size bed queen size bed and what we have
a helix mattress one of the like old
people beds oh really oh
when no where why i just go you can get
them at the they all have them really
yeah you guys use that thing for like
stuff yeah
sometimes i i put i uh he'll like bring
my [ __ ] up to him it's great it helps
you stand up i meant to watch tv that
was awesome it's so funny he brings the
bottom up because the bottom can go up
over the top
i'll just sit on the corner he just like
brings me up you need a standing desk
when you go to work dude yeah
i'm in how many pillows do you sleep
with uh i have one right now that's i'm
trying to cure my tmj i have tmj what's
that like the
jolt or whatever my joint and my jaw is
all [ __ ] up and it pops and stuff okay
and so i realized i was sleeping all
squashed like it sucks because i do like
to sleep like on my boyfriend's chest
like that but it's like i gotta
lay on my back so i don't grind my teeth
making improvements i'm really like and
hypnosis is helping me like my jaw was
like tight since i was yes molested
um the first time a little
um
no i'm really realizing all these things
like my body's been in fight or flight
since i was like okay i totally you know
i totally i didn't you just don't know
that i'm in you're in panic because
grinding your teeth at night when you go
to or or tmj or cluster hex i got all
these like tension problems
and when you go to the doctors they're
like we don't know what to do and it's
stress-related you're like [ __ ] you it's
stress-related like i'm not stressed or
whatever you know like
how do you stop being stressed and
hypnosis has worked like i just had this
lady she just programmed in my brain
my jaw is always relaxed especially at
night and it's just like more relaxed
than it's ever been in my entire life
damn it's crazy it's pretty cool
hypnosis yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
awesome i'm going to learn how to do it
too really
that scares me it gives me the heater
well you have to do you have to like
when i go
in the eye from here on out to be honest
i don't know how to do it i don't know
how to do it i don't know how to do it i
would never do it i got my underwears on
backwards that's the worst thing that
could happen i don't know the urinary
tract infection you get from your little
doo doo going in your pee
little skidmark i wear sheath it has its
own hole um
let's see what else anybody in your
family have adult braces
no okay
anybody in your family own a laundromat
bar or car wash no that's so fun anyone
in your family not trust the banks no
okay your parents never leave you
anywhere by accident yeah yeah her art
teacher's place yeah no that was on
purpose other than that
no we well
this shouldn't count swim practice
there was a mix-up of who was supposed
to be yeah that's okay but my mom also
really no one bathes without screamed at
that [ __ ] that was a good moment she
was like you [ __ ] left my kids [ __ ]
like it was good really it was good i
was like hell yeah you ever see any of
your parents fight
fist fight oh fistfights other people
you know no no fistfights but men did
tunk is my mom a lot in front of us
two men did it what do you mean
one we there was a family we used to go
camping with they tongue kissed her the
the man did which i think they were
trying to be swingers or something
uh-huh now as a kid as a grown kid did
your mom kiss back no what the [ __ ] she
was like what or she would a little bit
and then be like this is so weird and
then my my next door neighbor
what the [ __ ]
it's wonky i don't know we never
understood it like she's never given me
an answer like there's got to be an
answer that you're not telling me and
it's like you can tell me now mom you're
70. like yeah what am i going to do do
it on stage and tell everyone
[Laughter]
well i'm going to try to monetize this i
know it's like such a fine line with
them i'm like wait a minute
um but
they yeah no so he leaned in they he
stopped like waved to us when she was
driving in our minivan picking us up
from school or something and he just
leaned in a ton kissed and we were all
like
we're telling dad
yeah what'd your dad say he's just like
i was weird
what the [ __ ] but maybe they were all
swinging [ __ ] all over them maybe
they're all swingers
yeah it could be
no braces when you were a kid
i had a an appliance that yeah they said
i was a tongue thruster
and i
have veneers in now they're your teeth
no those are my teeth just rocks wow
fantastic shoes i think i don't like
veneers they've never looked good i
think they look terrible
they all you look like a clydesdale
every single one of you
yeah i don't like it at all it's like i
i don't think it's so jarring i feel
really like a hippie like i feel like i
want to like
i like to just like accept myself and
like you know i'll wear fake eyelashes
fake hair stuff like that but i will
always talk about it i'll never like be
about the [ __ ] i'm doing but i don't
have any botox i don't have any filler i
don't have any of that stuff like to me
it's just like i just want to like i
want to like
be who i am yeah yeah of course
never get a boob job or anything i'd
never do that
um let's see here growing up if you went
to like an amusement park or something
and you rode the roller coaster would
you do anything you went to dorney park
you rolled batman or whatever would you
get your picture would you buy the
picture was that a letterman thing you
would go to the gift shop
and wait and look at like screen nine
and buy your phone um
i don't i actually don't know if we got
the picture because there was one
picture i wanted to get my dad didn't
get it or my brother wanted to get
because we did i think this might have
been six flags there was something that
happened where my head i wasn't holding
my head right and i was getting my head
banged and the picture was like me like
like crying and wincing in pain and my
twin was like
and he wouldn't get it and it is one of
those things where i'm like [ __ ] you
should listen to max
what would be a typical letterman
vacation
uh cape may jersey shore
so it's jersey shore but it's cape may
it's literally sure how did you feel
because we were
we're wild why would we would go to
wildwood while we're there we got lost
there a lot they would lose us there
yeah oh yeah but it was usually my
brothers i didn't get lost as much but i
do remember like like pulling a man's
like sweatpants i'm like that and it
wasn't him like daddy ah you know yeah
funnel cake line like [ __ ]
yeah
these are my dad's pubes
uh
no i feel so lucky no one in my family
ever molested me or came clear there was
never anything my family
the only thing they're guilty of is like
not being as aware they're very like
just trusting of everyone uh-huh but
they never really leave maybe naive but
they never were
they weren't bad like that
no abuse they didn't hit us i mean i got
hit a couple times but i remember it you
know and they do too
if i got hit i deserved it yeah well i
think i'm like i'm like kind of
should have gotten it oh yeah i should
have got my dish i'm like i really
should have been had a little i should
have been smacking around yeah yeah just
to stay in line a bit yeah
have you ever won anything
lottery
my mom always wins like the gift basket
at things like if she's at something
where they're like put a ticket in she
always wins it yeah she's running the
auction property she's setting it up
what do you mean no she has weird like
win luck she won a trip to hawaii with
my dad when they were first married
um
there was a crepe contest like some
crepe
stuff
it was like a pineapple it was like you
know what it was like a pineapple i know
my brain i have to work on that because
i have to like paint pictures talking
about the french pancakes is that what
we're talking about yeah
but um
she it was like on canned pineapple or
something they had a contest where it
was like a crepe recipe and my mom
submitted and she won and then she and
my dad went to hawaii on a trip on a
crepe contest trip this is
literally nuts who watched you while you
were gone
that was when we were that was before we
were born but we had um our nanny slash
cleaning lady was this chick mavis
who would hang out with us
yeah she was from guyana
probably yeah i mean your dad was doing
well you got cash that's a big house
yeah big house how many bedrooms
three it was
they converted the third floor into two
bedrooms that was like an hour yeah and
it's two bedrooms
and then
they were my parents bedroom my
brother's bedroom my bedroom and then
there was a small room that they used as
an office
garage good-sized house garage yeah you
have a garage fridge
they my brother turned it into a um
thrasher stadium which was where they
would all smoke weed they got all these
couches from goodwill
turned it into like a place to smoke
weed there was a flag bomb that my older
brother named flaggy my brother's my
older brother
everything was named
the e of whatever it was
like puppy can you get me a copy so
funny
um but we did they changed did they
actually do construction on the plane or
was it just a garage no no my parents
were just like do your thing yeah so it
was a garage sale
but it's so funny because the light
would turn off after like two minutes so
they would have to hold the thing they
put a a glow in the dark sticker on it
so they would have to push the thing up
and down every two minutes so the light
would go back on so try i i hung out
in so many garages on couches smoking
whatever it's
a great time but they got us on an air
hockey table it is for sure the
trashiest house on the block yeah if
you're hanging out in the garage no pool
no pool but but we hung out at the local
pool but the garage but i'm just saying
like we were like the local pool yeah
we'd hang out at like yeah we'd go to
glenside pool we'd hang out there like
we're always on the swim team we're
always like just getting sunburned
but we would just go by ourselves did
you were you guys alone a lot as kids
yeah like you just wanted isn't it weird
now thinking about it hours it's cool
would you just like wand like we would
just walk to the pool like is that crazy
yeah i would just like hey leave in the
morning in the summer my parents are
going to work leaving them wanting to be
back for dinner
or we'd all be hanging out at somebody's
house totally normal totally normal
riding
hey it's noon i'm leaving
yeah whatever leave a note you haven't
even know like hey i'm but do you guys
have justin's would you
i feel like everything's too structured
now as far as family life where there
isn't time for like my niece and nephew
they don't have time to like disappear
and go hang out with their friends it's
something organized always in like
baseball soccer it's like your kid will
get snatched or something like i feel
like you can't have your kids just like
walking by themselves
no i don't yeah i mean i don't think
that happens anymore i think that's why
there's probably more [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that happened in the 70s 80s yeah
totally amazing you know
drink milk with dinner growing up
um
no but i would have been able to if i
wanted to do you like cottage cheese yes
i do you do uh
i haven't had it in years but i used to
my mom was on weight watchers
one of her weight watchers thing was
like the bird was big was toast with
cottage cheese and like
jam
that was pretty [ __ ] good honestly
uh well growing up what grocery store
did your parents go to
uh
not janardis what was around there
marty's is top-notch what's that fancy
yeah it's great it's good good marketing
we went to like shop right shop right
and then they would always change me
acme
now that my dad loves giant that's my
dad's favorite he's all checked out yeah
it's all right that's good middle school
but we never did yeah no we never were
like
trader joe's in high school
really in high school yeah damn you
trader joe's when you were in high
school they turned it into well maybe i
wasn't maybe i was in college but
it there was one in uh willow grove yeah
yeah yeah okay can we travel a little we
do a little extra yeah that's the liquor
store
i ever have a thumb ring
yeah toe ring uh yeah from the jersey
shore my mom and i would get like little
matching things
matching rings or whatever over there
okay
do you call it mini golf or putt-putt
mini golf okay putt-putt is trash i'm
going miniature golf maybe even yeah
miniature guys
yeah miniature golf mini golf but
putt-putt is a no-go
is it supermarket or grocery store to
you supermarket
is it book bag or school bag book bag
for life book bag for life okay and i
can't read so that's means a lot yeah
that's true dinner or supper dinner
not bad
but your parents still have a fax
machine
no
but they have a scanner
like they always said
my brother and i actually i should come
out as like
i i did some bad stuff okay my brother
and i when we had to do did you have to
do driver's ed like classes
for some reason we had to go to the
school we went to montgomery county
community college but we went in the
northeast somewhere somewhere in north
east village private like we were right
we had like i had the private guy did
you have norm that was just no remember
norms yes holy [ __ ] do you remember
norm's driving normally driving
he was that guy was yo norman is [ __ ]
round dude that big fatso i never got
those cards did they have do they have
two wheels in there yes he had a break
and a break in a steering wheel
and he was invited
he had a stutter big fat guy and he
would make you drive to his house to get
chips
what i might have did norm i just norbs
growing up every
normally
i don't know
no norm another one thank you for not
molesting me you had a perfect
opportunity shout out to norm
um wow that's that that just blew my
[ __ ] mind no we're gonna have a lot
of these norms driving schools like let
me come back on the show at some point
and we don't have to talk about three
we'll just talk about we'll find all of
our like philly things because there's
gonna be a million of them but so but my
brother and i might swim we went and did
the class at some college but it was in
northeast philadelphia somewhere and um
my mom had a xerox machine that you
could remember you could like make that
shrink things do you remember that you
would like re you would there was just
my mom had like this big ass
xerox machine and you could shrink stuff
and then you put it in like you put like
50 50 and then you make it like really
small
we stole the book
the book
to pass the class
and we shrunk it down we circled all the
right answers and we just handed it out
to these kids we didn't know them that's
great we just handed it out to all of
them everyone cheated everyone passed
and so we're probably like responsible
for a lot of vehicular manslaughters in
northeast philadelphia in the late 90s
so sorry about that around 1998. a
couple of people getting clipped on the
boulevard my boyfriend was four
playing instrument
uh just the recorder
not well just in school yeah but you
bought it for like six bucks i just
bought a new one over pandemic i was
like i'm gonna teach myself how to play
recorder and i was like no i'm not
that's is there a painting of your
family at your parents house by any
chance there is now but that's because
my older brother just got it wow of the
whole family no of them just of them
just of your parents but you know what i
got my boyfriend i got my boyfriend one
of those things from the mall that's
like the crystal where they etch in the
picture and it's on a light that box
that sounds trashy
i mean if you're getting this etching
done at the mall yeah it's in the middle
of the mall i'm a mobster yeah in the
middle of the mall i'm a male [ __ ] what
was your
and i got caught shoplifting at 14 they
took my blooming tails took my picture i
was stealing sunglasses they handcuffed
me to a bench was this like black guy in
a hawaiian shirt who's undercover so i
thought he was getting kidnapped by a
man like a stranger that's all so yeah
that's that's dicey it's so embarrassing
but how embarrassing is to be the guilty
one screaming for help yeah yeah
he handcuffed me to the bench i was like
ah someone help me
stranger danger and then they had a
paddy wagon they're like sorry [ __ ]
you're going in here i was like oh okay
jesus christ what's the credit card
situation now
um i i
it's i have one credit card
i had i had some mesis and some
bloomingdale's but we've moved on from
that cool yeah uh score credits didn't
close them but
but you know they do a thing where
they'll like just like charge you 10
cents every once in a while for
something don't worry and then you're
like you're like why is my credit
it's like because they like we'll be
like oh you didn't know about this one
dollar fee
is the credit good now
credit's growing credit's growing do you
know that money credit limits listen
credit limit is eight thousand on my
card right now but whoa but
i spend i'll spend over that but then
i'll keep paying it
the minute i started doing this [ __ ]
with jim ford i'm telling you wait
you'll make sure you pay the credit card
off at the end of the month i pay it
during the month so i can get more money
you know if you pay during so i'll pay
the 8 000 then i'll i'll pay like like i
just had to do it today i paid 2 000
towards it so tomorrow i'll be able to
spend more money on it now you use this
you you always use this when you make
purchases i'm trying to use it all the
time because it's my american airlines
one but my business manager just got a
business manager same one as tim dillon
well tim dillon told me he
he called me like a little while ago and
was like annie every everything can get
fixed with money he's like no
restaurant's closed
he's like you credit you just pay a guy
three thousand dollars it's up so
that's kind of where i'm at that's great
that's big egg ak is nice
if you go
like if you see something like i saw
this i mean this necklace was a little
bit
a little above the price range but i i
saw this necklace i go oh i want that
necklace and they were like it's 44
dollars and i was like uh but if they
had said four thousand dollars like i
would have made it work
yeah of course like it's like and i'm
not even saying like i'm gonna put out
to the universe that somehow i get that
[ __ ] like someone's gonna give it to
me or something i don't know like maybe
that will just end up in my place but
[ __ ] like that has been happening for me
like weird [ __ ] like that yeah yeah yeah
i'm a big proponent of like you have to
you know kind of believe you have to if
somebody
if you don't believe it who the [ __ ] is
going to believe but it's like if we go
like we don't deserve [ __ ] and we're
nothing like we're the only ones that
would even know that so it's like we're
just like letting people know we're
traveling yeah yeah yeah you know what i
mean it's just like
it's so weird i mean i it's
it's interesting to navigate in comedy
not being like a bitter prickly angry
[ __ ] anymore but well that's like new
before like it's just like when i see
somebody succeed now i'm like [ __ ]
great for you just because it's like
you're you're coming from a different
and the people that don't make it i was
talking to josh potter love josh potter
shout out to you shout out to him
but he but we like i've been like
telling i'm like i'm gonna ruin your
career so you have to be an opener for
me
i'm like this is a headliner you guys
are getting as an opener i know yeah i
will [ __ ] destroy him i was like i
will meet you if i have to [ __ ] not
he's the best but but with him it's like
i was talking to him it's like all these
people because i i mean i actually don't
remember him from new york but he knows
me from open mic scene
i was looking at my instagram like back
at one of my first ones and he had liked
it i'm like that's so sad i had no clue
who you were
[Laughter]
but so i was talking about it's like all
these people that like we used to look
up to don't even [ __ ] do comedy
anymore and you know what they all have
in common they're bitty bitter shitty
complaining focusing on what they don't
have like of course yeah yeah it's just
like
you just gotta be like stay in your own
lane and like focus on your [ __ ] i mean
still talk [ __ ] because it's fun but oh
yeah in the car yeah we play we play a
game called guess who stinks and it's
uh 20 questions like so you think of a
comic in your head and then you have 20
like you just go is it a guy or a girl
do they work here or there it's
the funnest game in the world it's so
weird what on the road um all right hit
us with all right we've got a couple of
patreon questions guys so when you sign
up for patreon we'll answer we'll ask
your garbage questions sign up it's
doing really well they're putting here's
the thing my patron i'd completely like
abandoned and i'm coming back to it so
don't worry about it now but check it
out a little bit but it's like
if you're if you do have people there
it's like you want to do more for it so
you should sign up for their patreon
because they actually give a [ __ ] about
you and they will be putting good
content on there it's like when you only
have like 20 people on youtube 100 it's
like all this work you want because you
want to give that to like the masses
yeah yeah yeah we put out a [ __ ] ton i
mean you get bonus episodes of ayg we do
a whole nother podcast on their hard
feelings we do live streams with the top
tier members and then we do the live
shows we shoot the live shows and then
put the live shows on
on there as well so there's a lot of
[ __ ] content and we love doing
everybody's awesome you know
um all right let's see
this is from k ever play
drinking games at a family function
uh that is a true mark of truth oh
drinking game is what
drinking jaeger and trying not to show
my tits to my entire grown family
yeah
yeah that's a game put that as a maybe
no i was getting blocked yeah i was it
was a nightmare yeah yeah i got i
actually oh i'm sad this is only going
on patreon but it's a good patreon no no
no this is no this goes okay guys uh so
i went to my my older brother was a part
of a frat he doesn't want me to say the
name of it but he was a part of a frat
at penn state and i went for parents
week and i was 16 years old
and poorly i had my nipples pierced um
16 years old i had your nipples pierced
at sixteen fourteen i got the second 14
did your parents know that this was
getting done uh no but when i was in a
fight with my mom when i was 14 i was
like i have sex i smoke cigarettes i
drink and i have my nipples pierced i
think that's one of the times i got hit
i got thrown on the bed for sure did you
get it done in a place or to the front i
went to south street tattoo
south street had to attach it to a 14
year old girl no they they they pierced
it and it is weird because you have to
touch my tit it's like
it's a i know what a nipple is is that
crazy i never thought about that until
more recently yeah it's crazy yeah
everything i've said has been nuts yeah
bananas and you guys are from philly i
feel like you wouldn't think it was like
crazy no i didn't get my nipples pierced
16.
[ __ ] gentlemen over here so penn
state fraternity house
family weekend i show up
we get um
my parents go back to the hotel we get
[ __ ] hammered at the at the hammer
drum just like drunk tequila all my
brother one of my brother's friends goes
uh like let's go shop for shot and i'm
like
only sister you know so i'm always like
trying to [ __ ] be as cool as the boys
unless you're a bit of a partier yeah i
already was a partner yeah
i was like dude
i'm about to graduate from high school
yeah uh
was your brother comfortable with this
i'm about to burn down the barrier no no
no no i mean he didn't care that we were
drinking but i don't he didn't he was
not comfortable with what happened so
what happens is i get hammered on
tequila and then my brother's friend
who's drinking shot taking shots with me
also has his double peers so he keeps
going oh you have your nipple pierced
let me see you i'll show you mine if you
show me yours right so then it turns
into a lion of my brother's friends
coming to see my
networks and i'm just flashing people
and they're like grandparents they're
like this is parents weekend i mean
we're at the party part but like some
parents yeah of course and then so the
next day it's family weekend
so the next day my brother's so mad at
me yeah and he's like and i'm like i'm
i'm looking back at this like i think
you should be mad at dave because dave
is [ __ ] 100 one over 18 who is like
you know what i mean it's also like i
killed i was the life of the party and
also i was [ __ ] story
[Music]
but um
yeah so the next day we didn't want to
tell my parents what happened so we just
said that i like i would say
well we wanted to they needed to know
there was some anger happening so what
the story we told was that i like threw
cake in someone's face so my brother
like i can't [ __ ] believe you threw a
cake in so many people's face
there was a line of people and you were
throwing cake in their faces so much
cake in so many faces um all right this
one's from matthew uh growing
tip i don't know this answer could go
either way uh growing up did you or your
siblings ever refer to your parents by
their first name never okay
that they drew the line at yeah i just
still call them like mommy and daddy
okay really you said mommy and daddy
i call my mommy my aunt's aunties
yeah surprise he's not aunt that's what
i don't know i think it's because no
wait i think i can change this back
because we caught everyone and aunt
nancy all that stuff my nieces call me
aunt they live in boston
so i think because i'm aunt okay
and then the boys called me aunt that
are in phil they're in jersey now but
okay
uh i want to go back though orange
really popped in i don't know how that
happened but it should be orange orange
orange orange um all right this will be
the last one this one's from michael uh
have you ever tried to charge food or
drinks to another room while staying at
a hotel if you're in room 305 or you get
your dinner and you say i'm in 308. you
don't do it in the hotel you're staying
at you go to a hotel you eat there and
then you just make up a number and you
leave yeah but you know when i did that
have you
trips with
hold on my school i have no idea where
this is going to end okay so my high
school the who goes on spring break it's
not going to be good
no it's no this is not it was oh this
was the summer i worked for the cartel
for three months wait just you guys how
i am alive i feel so good about myself
i'm so proud of myself it's so crazy but
i also have great stories is this the
prison school this was the yeah this is
the bad kids school i think they took to
mexico yes only once never again
i mean
my parents were donating money to this
[ __ ] school until two years ago when
i saw it in the mail i went you're
[ __ ] donating money to the school
that molested me jesus christ still yeah
what the [ __ ] no no not that you're not
a [ __ ] sign for your mom and dad not
now i got to cancel those free trials
man i know but so
okay so
the spring trips like some people would
go to oregon some people they had like
different trips they would do
ours they they were like we're going to
go to mexico we're going to go to cancun
it was during cinco de mayo we're going
to go to cancun to see the ruins to see
the mayan ruins right but all the
teachers were they were [ __ ]
not all of them were molesters but one
recently also got caught with kitty
point it's like it was like shady [ __ ]
was going on in that school in the 90s
damn it
the principal's gone i think he ran off
with a student
i don't know that for sure but i think
that's what happened with him [ __ ] the
bad school
it was a bad school we didn't realize it
did parents come on the trip to
chaperone or was it all no it was all
teachers and then so this is like a
[ __ ] racket i know so my my traffic
but my friend my friend milo whose name
is mk asante now he um he's got like
five names i don't know he's really very
we're like some pretty epic success
stories from the school but we hated
each other in high school we had got in
a fight they had to have us and they
were giving us a meeting in the
principal's office and i flicked a
booger in his face and he lunged at me
you flicked a booger in a guy yeah i did
milo was one to [ __ ] me up but anyway so
he um that's the craziest thing she said
he wrote a book he wrote a book about
he wrote a book about the school that
was like a bestseller really yeah don
cheadle don cheadle's like involved in
optioning as a movie great let's drag
he's [ __ ] bozos through the mud he's
but he i think his was about the school
being good and then we reconnected we
reconnected and we started remembering
all the [ __ ] and we started remembering
all this [ __ ]
but he like he just has a different
relationship but
but he like he was like oh my god and
then our friend dustin who passed away
but he was he was in acting so i knew
someone didn't make it through it no a
lot of people died but dustin just
doesn't have um diabetes complications
but which we're
we're worried about but um
careful um
but dustin was uh
diabetic
dustin was a um
an acting coach and he had all these
acting schools and he worked with like
all of will smith's kids and stuff like
he did really well too but so milo um
dustin and malo
were in
cancun the same time i was but we
weren't friends yet we didn't become
friends grown-ups recently like 10 years
ago
um
he um he and dustin were like at strip
clubs and [ __ ] like 16. you're in
[ __ ] cancun
we were um
yeah we were just drinking 16 in cancun
you might as well be 38 but we went on a
booze cruise
with the they took the teachers took us
on a booze cuz and i won a striptease
contest at 14 i want a bottle of tequila
and they took the tequila for themselves
but that's it that's i mean
you're doing a [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
insane that's so crazy and dustin he's
like i have pictures of he passed away
so i don't have the pictures but there
are somewhere at his mom's house he has
pictures of me is that not the best tbt
you've ever seen in your [ __ ] life
that's like an album cover
that's an owl beast
isn't that insane but that's where we
did the thing we're getting
testimony yeah i know
i always get scared that i'm getting
sued by people for telling these stories
but soon what do you mean you were the
victim i know but i guess you get scared
i don't know hey this girl melissa keeps
talking about it what the [ __ ]
no when i talked about it on marriage
being bygones when i talked about it on
marion i didn't say the teacher's name
or the school or anything because i was
like
like very still very very like
traumatized and scared
um
he
someone figured out who he was just from
what i said and he had been he had moved
to another state and was just starting
to work with at-risk youths again and i
[ __ ] blocked his ass again nice yes
good for you look at that [ __ ]
superhero over here
driving her tesla from town to town
annie
stopping their duels
eight thousand dollar credit limit tesla
new two-bedroom apartment what is
successful with a loft with a loft
successful boyfriend on tour
podcast is killing it sold out my last
weekend
sold nice
where were you i was in uh
arizona and tempe arizona great caroline
almost not the full weekend almost sold
out the entire weekend though caroline's
this weekend is that correct yes
caroline's this weekend
fantastic
i'm doing uh trash but i am garbage but
i'm making the best of it and so can you
trash but also go to annieletterman.com
you can see all my other tour dates i'm
on i'm on the road a bunch i'm going to
like
next i'm in hartford then i go to
um
i'm going to be in like chicago and
we got a big chicago beast go out and
see her yeah love it yeah i got a bunch
of stuff coming super funny
gonna go down
there gonna go go into uh going to death
valley to do drugs with doug stand up
and all his boys really yeah there you
go gonna be fun that'll end well work
hard play hard baby
i like it mushrooms what else you want
to know is that it
i got merch i got uh drawings that i
drew that are doing really well very
cool i like to be able to share my
drawings with people love it throw them
on my shirt so you can find those at any
letterman.com too trash tuesday check
out my podcast i also have my solo
podcast will be coming back so you can
follow me on youtube for that and watch
all my old episodes of my old podcast
they're great love it we love it kippy
what do you got for them guys uh you
know just subscribe rate review the
whole nine yards youtube patreon uh buy
the merch while it's still available and
get it while it's hot live shows we keep
announcing more dates we have a [ __ ] ton
of dates coming up so check them out
what a [ __ ] episode bonkos boncos
annie i can't be the biggest piece of
trash you've had no it's just wild
stories
i have so many i got to write a book
yeah 100
i know you need to write a book wild
stuff we love you thank you thanks so
much gang we'll see you next week